hello freak [ __ ] you know whether
it's through warfare or disease or some
new government usurping the old power or
whether it's through predators and prey
and there's always some weird sort of
reaction to something gaining too much
power we are its ideas or ideologies or
patterns they gain too much power and
then something shows up that sort of
tends to diminish that and Rohde the
very foundation of it now that's what I
feel about psychedelics that in many
ways what they're doing and even the
sneaky door like the people to talk
about cannabis being you know some sort
of a gateway drug look it's not a
gateway drugs are the bad ones I think
right if anything it's a gateway drug to
the ones that are going to change the
world yeah
if it doesn't do it on its own if yeah I
mean this concept of a gateway drug is
you know it's just stupid if it says
this is something that the drug warriors
have come up with you know I mean I'm
here to tell you coffee is a gateway
drug alcohol is one couplet ice cream is
a gateway drug we've all taken these
things and you know look where we are
now right we know so gateway drug it's
just the concept is absurd what's it if
it was that sold in a in a environment
where there were a choice to have all
sorts of other illegal drugs it wouldn't
be a gateway drug with it no well the
alcohol one is the most ridiculous one
because it's everywhere and it's the one
that inhibits your releases your
inhibitions more than any other drug may
is responsible for the most foolish
behavior yeah it's everywhere you can
get it at every restaurant you can get
it almost everywhere you go this way
even to the point where it's not even
recognized as a drug yeah exactly
cognitive dissonance for years you know
the FDA could not classify tobacco as a
drug because it was a different
regulatory framework full of course it's
a drug you know and somebody said yeah
it's the only drug you can use when used
as instructed will kill you
that's hilarious it's really funny that
the word drug I'm not funny but it isn't
it problematic at the very least the
word drug is sort of this gigantic
blanket that we throw over all these
things that perturb consciousness right
well Metro good and bad yeah positive
and negative
no beneficial effects whatsoever and a
massive this is another reason this is
another example of why this conversation
about drugs is so shallow because we're
talking about drugs - completely scary
as you said people don't use drugs what
about what about which drugs when we
talk about which drugs because there's
thousands of drugs so which one are we
talking about or we just ban all drugs I
feel like just calling the drugs is a
problem yes yes it means how could you
call DMT the same thing you call alcohol
it seems to me to be so crazy
it's just not a useful term right you
know and then also I mean the problem
that they're facing and that we have to
acknowledge which I've been saying a lot
lately is you know we're made of drugs
right
that's why drugs work we are made of
drugs right
we are biochemical engines that run on
drugs which are neurotransmitters and
hormones and enzymes and all these
things in biochemical system they're
involved with signal transduction with
you know organisms are networks of
communication they're mediated by
neurotransmitters neurotransmitters if
you isolated them from the brain put
them into a bottle and sold them that
would be a drug well there's a drug so
this idea that you know we are
inherently biochemical systems you know
and people don't want to acknowledge
that but that's the truth you know we're
made of drugs so the people that want to
have the drug free America I'm sorry
you know we're made out of drugs drugs
are built into who we are now that way
drugs taken from plants or from the
outside have the effects that they have
you know because they affect these
systems but you know our big brains this
is kind of a consequence of evolution
you know we have these enormous brains
you know will it evolve very quickly and
we like novelty you know we have all of
these brain receptors we like to we like
to stimulate those receptors because it
makes us feel good or what's interesting
or for all sorts of reasons we like to
tweak our states of consciousness it's
just built into who we are you know and
it's not a bad thing well this is a
problem with the way you're thinking you
have too many facts and used too much
science and you don't have enough easy
Horrocks you have enough Jesus in your
life if you had Jesus you would need all
this nonsense
and then that Jeff Sessions would make
sense to you right stop may be true but
unfortunately I don't
so yeah I'll just continue to be deluded
didn't believe in science was just so
important some things like it's so
important that you embrace Jesus and you
just want I can't do it I mean I I did
it right a recovery Catholic I've been
there I know I know the drill I know the
territory
[Applause]
[Music]